SAMSONOV HAS BEEN ABLE TO ROTATE
WITH SHUTOUT SO FAR GOING
TO FINISH THEIR CHECKS.
>> OUT TOP.
LEAVES IT.
OVECHKIN DRIVE, AINE ALONG THE .
AND IT'S BEHIND LELE WORK IT TH.
MARTINEZ WITH A WRIST SHOT
SCORES.
EN
THE PADS OF SAMSONOV.
YOU CAN MATERIALIZED.
OVECHKIN AND WILSON BREAK.
McNABB HAVE THE
2-1 LEAD.
WELL, JOHN CARLSON'S BEEN BIG B,
MASSIVE BREAK, FOR VEGAS.
>> Referee: WOR THE
GOLDEN KNIGHTS, AND PETER DeBOEN
MAN IN KUZNETSOV.
LOOSE PUCK 7 ALL TIME.
GOES TO THE
LOGAN THOMPSON, HIS THROUGH THE.
ORLOV LOOKING TO START IN FRONT,
.
DADONOV
DEEP BACK OUT, AND THE SHOT HE
WANTS BABA FOR
THE SECOND TIME TONIGHT.
LOOKING TO GRAB THEIR FIRST LEA.
AND CHANDLER STEPHENSON
REDIRECTS IT PERFECT SCORE.
ALEX OVECHKIN RIPS IT IN, HIS C,
AND THAT IS UNDER THE ARM ASAS .
BRINGS IT DOWN TO WILLIAM
TRIED TO FIND MARCHESSAULT UP
FRONT.
OH, THERE'S ONE.
>> Shane: THEY NEED TWO POI THE.
TO THE